[Music]
and something isn't adding up news that
makes ASCO submitted by excited for
danger boys a man who was supposedly
fired from his job years ago was
arrested while collecting his paycheck
but oh because he was still getting paid
I never said anything Shady
is it shady is it shady yes cuz he's not
putting in any work is it though
absolutely what is Oh okay so but
they're not they're not tell you well
what if they didn't know he didn't know
he was fine
sometimes I pay bills not even know that
I did but he showed up for work every
day now it's paid for Wall Street
Journal for like two years and every
touch it but you were getting it though
so that's a different thing
oh that's true that happened to me I was
paying for Kindle subscription and
renting this one Kindle book for I think
like nine months and it came out to like
300 something dollar I don't even own a
Kindle I don't know how I accidentally
clicked this on Amazon one day but I
have been renting that book three
hundred and something dollars worth of
that book was it a sick book yes I don't
know I don't like indle I'll never know
did you know Jeff was like you dumb
[ __ ] we got to cancel this with a
Swedish accent on no Jo Jo Jackson if
you want well he should yell at you in a
few sections so that it's consistent of
course be some sleep he's from Sweden
Sweden you're like five minutes ago it
sounds a lot more like British though
because he worked in restaurants for
thirteen years where it was just like a
melting pot of different cultures and
ethnicities and a lot of them were were
British or they spoke English even
though they were from Denmark or
Scandinavia or anywhere like that's just
how they speak English does he sound
like Jamie Lannister
oh god no that fake accent is so creepy
oh well you don't like that fake accent
no I think it's so charming wait is it
which one am I thinking I'm Nicholas
Coster what I really know we're short
one with the fake accent
yeah oh yeah yeah but don't you just
like them anyway no it's got a fake
little accent
oh that's what's so fake it's so bad
it's very Charlie Hunnam terrible actor
Joe he's American him and um what's her
name
no no she's British dammit passed in my
ear Dinklage that's cuz we don't know
yeah he's American so we're talking
about Ronald weird my [ __ ]
fantasy what's your fantasy you never
seen him in anything else nope
cuz Hawkes is real I thought you was
famous in Britain never seen elf oh yeah
I was again yeah he was the little guy
in the CEO or whatever oh it was the
evil trying to [ __ ] around the fact that
you were trying to hold a nice man
well because you looked at me like that
anyway so ronald here he's 47 he has
claimed that he's been on sick leave
since 2015 for high blood pressure and
asthma how sick is his moment he had a
person Adam I think he's fine yeah he
has gone to the city transit office
every two weeks to sign in and pick up
his paycheck without a problem so he has
collected roughly two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars before so because he's
a subway cleaner by the way so before
some way someone at the MTA realize that
there was a problem and
like what the hell house is dude still
collecting a check like he got fired so
there's this reporter that approached
him and saying like wait why are you
still collecting checks if you got
terminated back in 2013 he was like if I
got fire than how my still collecting
checks that seems like the [ __ ] is that
my fault
the logic stands up but the faults on
the MTA side
oh that's shady dude no better [ __ ] you
so then that's when the boss told him
that's not my problem that's payrolls
problem oh what a shady dude man I would
have been like I thought the whole
severance pay for my high blood pressure
do you think when this happens for like
nine months he's like I got it all
figured
I'm sure dude right yeah high blood
pressure and asthma is like what I said
I had to get out of the Pacer test in
elementary school yeah that's why I
didn't want to run the mile in PE I'm
like well I think I got a is
yeah this is what he looks like
Ronald shady shady shades is the
reporter which one which one oh sorry
Ronald reporter hey what do you say he's
not my phone yeah yeah I forgot to like
mention who's who because he kind of
looks like he's like [ __ ] I'm so
collecting text already works
I like the was also saying like I didn't
know it was terminated if I was
terminated then why am I still getting
letters from them the last one I got was
at the end of last month and I believe
it was for for asbestos training or
track training but if they would have
sent me a termination letter like let me
know I could have just already been
filing for unemployment so but he got
arrested when you he wants to go pick up
his last check because they triggered it
as him trust trespassing because he's no
longer employed because now they're they
use biometric fingerprint or are they
gonna come after his money but they're
just like bucket keep it Oh that'd be
nice yeah
we [ __ ] up yeah 250 K though so he was
charged with criminal trespassing that's
what he got arrested for but in terms of
his pay I don't know cuz that fraud like
MTA is gonna be investigating and that's
when they will like a Bank of America
dumped 50k into my bank account tonight
and I was to spend it or the jaw or
whatever that's fraud right absolutely
and then you were responsible to pay
back so what's the dealy absolutely
would be your money
dippy is that you don't work for bake of
America I think that's the driver but he
doesn't work for these kids well he does
work and he would just didn't know he
was terminated right and then every week
could giving him checks till he that's a
that's a difficult that's a little bit
harder so from what I understand is he
hasn't actually put in any hours like a
actual work he doesn't need to visit he
was on yeah exactly so he was like well
I've been on sick leave this whole time
I'm still getting a check I still signed
in every week every two weeks and get my
check like how was I supposed to know I
got fired because what if he every time
he goes like okay so when do I start
work again and they're like I don't
worry about all right skew the check in
the night and he's signing for it he's
coming in he's getting it all right well
Matt anytime you convinced me I don't
know the tax payer part of me is like
all your
our money and then the other part of me
is just like good for you man take the
system I would spend it if if that was
happening to me I'd be so scared I
wouldn't really yeah we do I'd be
frightened cuz I'm just like I what am i
doing to deserve this and then I'm like
like I'm stealing leaf and then you keep
asking for hours I don't worry about
what I only gave you hours I would still
be like this is him right like something
about this doesn't feel right
you're a good person yeah well she's not
a good person I'm not I'm really not mom
yes I understand that the investigation
will follow the facts and anyone who
inappropriately took public money will
be held accountable to the full extent
of the law
this is like when you see those things
it's like an armored car the door ripped
open or the work they rolled the windows
down a bunch of cash blew out on the
freeway and it's like if you took any
cash you're going to prison
you should I think I was there for that
but that's what I'm saying I'm like
these peoples lucky day man come on now
that's [ __ ] up even be not mean I'd
say you know what they just print that
[ __ ] anyway so for a few thousand of you
guys go ahead and take some take it and
run
I just think of the grandmas and
grandpas that just don't have them it's
fdic-insured exactly up to $100,000 okay
oh no next time I'll uh you know party I
have no feelings toward money like no
moral right or wrong toward it me too
yeah because it's just pretend
just makes me uncomfortable because we
print it yeah it's it's literally yeah
there's no moral thing to it we need to
go back to the Bitcoin thing I mean if
you think about how chase was able to
excuse all of the people in Canada like
it's literally a flip of a switch so the
only concept behind it is that people
agree that it has value that's the only
thing so if a few people decide to steal
it or whatever like I'm like you're not
crazy the [ __ ] that comes out of his
mouth sometimes right cuz you'll see
some like some like really deep [ __ ] the
most part he's just [ __ ] chewing on
see with you I couldn't differentiate
his real voice versus his like that's
the real one yeah the best thing is we
all get to just talk about it he gets to
sit there at the fish
he always as a straight look on his face
and then his face doesn't bow but he
just blinks and looks around the room
looks disappointed that we've taken the
let off observing you all that's all
that sounds judging I think it's not
judging we're monkeys in this wool
[ __ ] world fest I don't even know
who's making fun of who the ultimate
remember losing dudes yeah we probably
are anything so that's your assessment
of me thank you very much how come you
guys have a feeling with money like that
it just makes me uncomfortable what
makes you uncomfortable stealing I don't
like talking about money I don't like
discussing it any time I have to check
my bank account I break out in hives
that's very interesting
I just don't like it is ayat II yeah I
don't have anxiety but it does make my
heart beat a little bit faster like
whether it's good or bad like you know
even when I was making nothing versus
like now when I'm doing a little bit
better like it's it I don't like talking
about it it was the most
oh god it's always the most awkward
thing ever when you have to discuss it
which you have to do when you're in a
long-term relationship because then you
merge finances what what it what is it
about that that makes it awkward most
likely so my question is basically so I
don't get it because I just didn't know
so so a lot of people are they have bad
finances right yeah I think the main
reason is because of that whatever you
just explained right now is very common
with a lot of people it's a very
uncomfortable conversation to have with
themselves they don't even want to touch
that topic in their own minds so I'm
like I'm trying to discover that because
I have this concept called the Joe
malian Academy and I teach people how to
run their finances and budgeting and
things like that and although I look
like yeah it looked like a complete
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm telling you that I
have struck gold in life and I just
wanted to play it forward and give that
information that's awesome so one thing
he could monetize all this but he didn't
individual I give that idea really for
free because things like this is very
interesting to me cuz I'm like wow I
never had this association of discomfort
so I I want to know that so that's
that's my motivation for the question I
have a career coach and the one thing
that she kind of just like tried to
instill really hard on me
to keep saying this mantra to myself
that numbers are power until like not be
afraid
cuz I mean it's not that I'm not doing
well it's that even if I am doing well I
I have these fears of like well all of
this is before taxes all of this is
before this and all like all of that and
I think it's because I was raised to
like never never discuss money never
complain about money never complain
about sacred cause to lack not so much
it's it's kind of rude to talk about
money especially I've gone out to dinner
with some friends and they'll look at a
menu and be like this is so [ __ ]
expensive and oh god just statements
like that make me so uncomfortable what
it what comes out the feeling of like
the lack mentality that she's hearing
what do you mean
well it's like a lack mentality to be
like like oh I'm afraid of losing money
or I'm afraid of this menu because it's
someone no no no they see their expenses
like oh are you that broke no it's not
even that that's not how I'm thinking
it's it's more so like look why do you
have to bring money into this like
you're you maybe you're looking at the
most expensive thing on the on the menu
like why don't we just enjoy the meal
for what it is yes responsibly I see
what could you slightly eat the bread
and drink water honestly to be that's
more harmonious if you really can't
afford if you just sit here and then
just just the time a good time and talk
about what we it's kind of like bringing
politics into like dinner and it's like
why the [ __ ] did we had to do that we
just ate the turkey it was a big to-do
and me and Robert had to sit down and
like discuss finances and how we were
going to start merging them and
everything like that you know one thing
I feel like a lot of you I don't know if
this applies to you but a lot of people
I feel like that feel anxious when it
comes to looking at money is that
finally in their life there's a
numerical objective attachment to their
behavior or value so and because of that
now they're finally held accountable for
who they are as a person like okay I'm
spending this much or not spending this
much or I'm paying this much or I'm not
paying it it's like oh [ __ ] like it's
like a rating system for who they are as
a person and then they're they don't
want to come face to face of that so
every time they have to open up their
bank account and check their finances
like I don't even want to look at the 12
pairs of jeans I bought yeah or they see
that number as their value and and that
is a sinking ship even though maybe
perhaps the work that they're doing is
taking them to out of that level and
into a higher value they don't see that
in the moment they just see where
they're at yeah you are not your credit
score people mm-hmm you are not well you
actually really are your credits work
then I'm a bad for America
[Music]